[Música]
hay una vía en directo américa de
france24 daniela nuevamente acá con
nosotros esta mañana jueves en el
estudio vamos a eeuu porque allí están
cerca de un acuerdo para evitar una
huelga ferroviaria que tiene límite
mañana así es raúl lo veremos qué pasa
en el transcurso del día pero por ahora
después de que una de las compañías que
se llama amtrak comenzará a cancelar
algunas rutas de pasajeros de larga
distancia el presidente yo bailé en
reveló que las principales compañías y
sus sindicatos que representan a unos
115 mil trabajadores ya tienen un pacto
tentativo para evitar este cierre del 30
por ciento del transporte tanto de carga
como de pasajeros algo que costaría unos
dos mil millones de dólares por día no
se conocen los términos del acuerdo pero
sí que tienen hasta este viernes para
firmarlo el tema fue debatido
ampliamente en el senado que tiene la
potestad de lanzar una ley de emergencia
en caso de que llegue a firmarse esta
webcam
y resulta que el tema clave en las
negociaciones actuales no son los
salarios aparentemente hay un acuerdo
sobre eso el tema clave que se cuestiona
es sobre las condiciones de trabajo en
la industria que son absolutamente
inaceptables y casi increíbles cuando
moscú en este momento si usted trabaja
en la industria ferroviaria de carga uno
de los trabajos más agotadores y
peligrosos de eeuu tiene derecho a un
total de cero días de enfermedad
y estaban yo nos vamos a europa dani
porque los ministros del g7 de economía
se reúne en ese momento en alemania así
es raúl y el plato principal es la
guerra en ucrania por supuesto este
encuentro se desarrolló a las afueras de
berlín entre los ministros de comercio
del grupo conformado por alemania
francia italia japón canadá eeuu y reino
unido una de las opciones que están
contemplando es ampliar ese periodo de
un año que inició en junio pasado en el
que no sólo está cobrando derechos de
importación a los productos que
provengan de ucrania
desde junio ya hemos liberalizado
completamente nuestro comercio con
ucrania brindándoles pleno acceso al
mercado de la unión europea varios
socios del g7 han hecho lo mismo esta
medida está vigente por un año por lo
que recibimos una solicitud del vice
primer ministro de ucrania para extender
más una discusión que ya hemos indicado
desde el lado de la comisión europea si
la situación lo requiere estaríamos
listos para extender ese plazo y hay
indicios positivos de alemania- de que
están dispuestos a apoyarlo y la gigante
de ventas amazon danny fue demandada en
el estado de california sí señor como ha
sido también demandada en otros estados
previamente tras una investigación de
más de dos años la fiscalía del estado
acusa a la compañía que es dueño de un
40 por ciento de las ventas en línea en
estados unidos de violar las leyes
antimonopolio y de competencia porque
les impone estrictas reglas a sus
vendedores sobre los precios de los
productos
en archivo word amazon evitó competir en
precios con otros sitios de comercio
electrónico en línea desde al menos 2012
entonces durante una década les exige a
los vendedores que celebrarán contratos
que los penalizaba severamente si sus
productos se ofrecían a un precio más
bajo que en amazon
spence estas prácticas evitan la
competencia básica de precios y les
cuestan más a los consumidores al evitar
que las diferentes tiendas en línea
compitan para superarse entre sí con
precios cada vez más bajos pues no ver
en la web países y cómo están los
indicadores económicos o street abrió en
rojo hace pocos minutos también se
acaban de conocer datos sobre peticiones
de auxilio por desempleo que bajaron
esta semana a 213 mil este es el menor
nivel desde finales de mayo y un indicio
de que empleo sigue fuerte en europa el
principal índice parisino cac-40 se
dirigía a un cierre negativo después de
conocerse que en francia el índice de
precios al consumidor en agosto fue del
o el aumento en ese índice fue del 66
por ciento interanual un día después de
que el gobierno decretara un tope al
alza de los precios en 2023
y hacerlo con mínimas variaciones al
alza están todos esperando las
decisiones de política monetaria que
tome la reserva federal la próxima
semana y como siempre muchísimas gracias
por toda la información económica mañana
con más por supuesto